Over the years I've been making videos,
a lot of people have got in touch
to tell me that in Warsaw, in Poland,
the tap water quality is tested
and controlled by clams.
They said that the city
constantly runs a sample of its tap water
past some mollusks.
And those are filter feeders,
so if there's a contaminant in the water,
they will instinctively close.
Sensors attached to them
will detect that and raise the alarm.
And I didn't believe it.
It seemed too weird to me.
And all the articles that I could find
about it seemed dodgy, somehow.
They just set off red flags
in the research parts of my brain.
There is a very arty Polish documentary
about the system, and a lot of sites
repost that film’s claims
without even mentioning the source,
just as a “look at this
funny thing off in Poland!”.
It felt like it could be a misinterpreted
or mistranslated joke,
or even a deliberate hoax by a filmmaker
that got out of control,
and that the English speaking world
was just believing it
because it was quirky and harmless enough.
There have been plenty of fake
things like that spread about in the past,
accidentally or otherwise.
Or maybe the clam-sensors did exist,
but it was a brief experiment
that never went anywhere.
Well, I'm now here in Warsaw,
on a famous building
in the middle of the river, with a Polish
speaking team showing me around.
There is a lot of stuff we are not allowed
to film here for security reasons.
Inside here is critical infrastructure.
Plus, it is far too noisy down there
for me to talk, but
I'm happy to report that yes,
the clams are real.
They actually do protect Warsaw,
but the story's a little more
complicated than that.
IN POLISH:
The important thing is: those clams aren't
the only protection.
They're not even the main part.
This is still a modern
water treatment system,
with 21st century sensors and
detectors to keep everyone safe.
This is part of a defense in depth,
one part of an early warning system,
one more alarm that can go off,
like an airport that uses
explosive sniffing dogs...
but also electronic detectors.
The technical term
for this is “biomonitoring”,
and it turns out from more research that
this isn't the only place that does it.
There are other water companies in Poland
that have similar setups,
plus one in Minnesota, USA,
and probably more that I haven't found.
At which point I think I can say that:
yes, the red flag in my head was wrong.
The clams in this building
really do help protect Warsaw.